toi tu yannick ekoko inversée historique
[Musique]
highlight the study sa mère dont la
mélodie froide les gamins sa fait ça les
gars ça me casse avec ses doigts on a le
même cerveau
[Musique]
tout le monde a toujours dans le placard
je suis non non je vais rentrer laissez
moi aussi d aline au tchad ferme la
porte le meurtrier tutu l'un des deux
est ensuite j'ai où ils sont tous noirs
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il fallait en
juillet qu'un seul cyril la c1 est vite
fait et lucas est comme moi comme moi ça
fait trop cramé à temps quand je met
dans votre tête tu en penses quoi
j'ai entendu un truc on a compris ici
devant vous la faites en son
[Musique]
jabbar et à la nage est passé par la
maison tard j'avais pas que y arriver il
fallait pas qu'ils amènent par derrière
[Musique]
il ya deux personnes quand même skin ici
non non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on se met tout cela comme ça moi
je
québec je suis innocent ben moi je vais
faire moi pour igol petite salle au clan
dsk banon jet-ski amado
non mais vous êtes nazaire tuant deux
raquettes et la manne qui a compris les
annonces au calme bon excusez moi qu'est
ce qu'il s'est passé là non mais non
mais pour deux mais le sort de mustapha
yssingeaux lui dis bien aucun effort
laplaud jim il ya deux fois mais je les
ai fait la descendance jambes étaient là
comme au caire jacou démoli mais lucas
est un [ __ ] de casiers qui vais pas à
ce bordel
mais laissons les sons de -2 venait de
la pièce au bout vraiment
humiliation sentiment de honte ressentie
après une atteinte à la fierté exemple
squeeze va faire semblant d'être courant
pour éviter l'humiliation auprès de ses
copains mais sa quasi normal gros c'est
pas ça attends attends je veux c'est
autre chose mais je comprends pas ok
vous avez pris un engagement direct
ouah ouah ouah je vais aussi comme la
personne mais non mais il espère ou quoi
là
non mais je vous laisse faire les
gardiens mais arrête des jaloux amer
regarde le mec il est actuellement pas
celui canal avec tout le monde passe
venez vous éclater avec c'était le plus
gros qu'ahmad le tweak faire un petit
mix vous disent que vous en pensez j'ai
besoin de vos avis pas contrôler les
armes c'est pas autorisé sur le
dancefloor vraiment alors je fais partie
ça n'a pas trop quoi penser quoi dans le
grenier les enfants cyril où es-tu série
le crosnier au futur dans le grenier
bonjour si et les tentes heures de
larmes qu'il se meurt c'est papa c'est
papa toi tu es une chambre tuant trois
de montée au paradis du grenier
merci je fais porter non attends tu
pêches dans sa strate mais s'ajuste
j'ai mal au cul ouais mais vannes et des
pages doit que j'aille paloc quand même
pas un objet abeilles à toi castelet la
plus grande merde je le demande est
connu il s'étend maintenant la meuf qui
au final se paie d'arbres de [ __ ]
ok les pandas box où elle cache un gros
mot la poubelle et vous attend comme le
plus j'ai peur aux plats
c'est mouradia le guichetier voulez quoi
un [ __ ] alors à quoi bon
or de laval sous la tente est allé
prêter aux bureaux paris a donné des
crédits à ceux qui le souhaitent
regarde ma cachette puis il trouvera pas
sa démission de luca et tâche et non
mais attends mais qui reste deux minutes
tu donnes pas d'avis quand il ya 2000
donne quoi mais là tu n'as pas ta
thébaux g de faire du bruit je suis
qu'un par contre là c'est pas normal là
oui ça va bien avec le décor mais c'est
pas normal
je veux la levée petite toilette quoi
celle là c'est normal mais on doit guy
non mais vraiment là vous exagérez
complètement vrai nom banalise pas du
tout à l'heure en plus quelqu'un lui
quelques ajustements de juste devant toi
vous avez dit pas qu'elle avait d'abord
dit vous avez des attentats que soient
les autres parce que j'ai toujours été
content a changé de pied quand je suis
parti oui j'entends rien ou quoi
vous avez inventé gérard par les jets
dois m'exprimer n'ai eu qu'un deuxième
strophe winter shittu ce qu'elle
écoutait
1 2 3 soleil oh [ __ ] vous êtes fan de
soleil et à bouger vous avez bougé celui
qu'attend la porte il alla romana gas je
ne suis pas celui tient la porte celui
qui est à la porte
il a la liberté les gars 1 2 3 soleil
soleil a le droit au soleil mais pas les
inspire automne sur la piste de danse
retour sur un beat way avait des oisifs
est tombé wef et ont mis cette occasion
manquée
il était allé aux larmes on va alors la
musique m'a fait perdre la tête
regardez bien ça sera dans un espace on
dit d'ailleurs revoyez le faire via leur
fai diamantaire
je sais la meilleure chose
[Musique]
sofiane tête bon j'ai hâte de voir le
pouvoir devrait de maxence analyse la
mg3 de voir qu on sait pas qu elles ont
fait quelques sacrifices immédiats aux
mécanos saute à l'oeil
l'amicale comme la pauvreté vite ville
mais tu dis tu peux même temps l'état de
santé de mouss puis je les paye j'ai
fait demi tour
sortez sortez sortez
j'ai fermé la porte et la médaille
les voitures ne sait trop bien son
couvre la police municipaux tour ces
palabres sur la route des côtes
japonaises
oui c'est là qu'ils sont sentis je suis
mort vous avez pour qu'aussi bien la
caisse dans la caisse pourquoi tu me
fuis moi je te sérieux lundi qu'il s'est
plu à 6
bah ouais de toi il ya deux tu peux
remonter quoi mais j'ai fini mais bon
c'est le premier à trois noms sur le
premier à 3 est le premier à trois noms
non non non non le premier à 3 mais si
on m'avait dit déjà reçu leurs diplômes
et de la rue c'est ce qu'on avait dit
des laveurs de vitre est une pratique
tu crois que les pertes s'élèvent dans
la vie je croyais jamais en vo amis qui
sont des grosses merdes
taillon vous laissez moi déçu
y'a du solde white a tout donné et a été
traitée s'était taillé tard god tête à
gauche tout le soma graves doit arrive
ce n'est pas grave tu as traversé tous
quand même à faire croire à tout le
reste
un peu avant d'engager un piège on a
failli au pied aulas n'ont rien
voyageurs avec la trouille à piano je te
jure ya un piège je sais pas ce que
c'est bien piège 3 payen flèche et en
avait un gros et ont repris mais y alla
de williams et biz à leur égard
c'est tout
bah
les pieds
pour m
[Musique]
m